bonjour estelle l'hémicycle qui a donc
finalement voté tard dans la nuit ce
projet de de sortie progressive de
gestion crise impératif pour la suite en
tout cas
oui magali leur a fallu une deuxième
délibération est une réécriture de
l'article 1 avec 208 voix contre 85 le
projet de loi de sortie progressive de
l'état d'urgence sanitaire a finalement
été vous l'avez vous l'avez dit adopté
par l'assemblée nationale un vote
nocturne qui intervient donc après un
camouflet pour le gouvernement camouflet
infligé un par ses alliés du modem le
modem qui a demandé initialement des
précisions sur le passait sanitaires les
élus elle souhaitait aussi raccourcir la
période de transition qui permet à
l'exécutif de conserver à certains
pouvoirs pour lutter contre une reprise
éventuelle de l'épidémie plus
globalement le modem a dénoncé un manque
de dyala des de dialogue et d'écouté de
la part de l'exécutif propose d'écouter
la porte parole du modem on vote sur
quoi comme le gouvernement a des
pouvoirs exorbitants ils mettent ensuite
tout ce qu'il veut dans le décret
le passage au banc de l'assemblée formel
il y à peu d'attention du gouvernement à
notre endroit voire un certain mépris
un son de cloche que l'on retrouve aussi
à chez les élus de l'opposition l'est
républicain par exemple dénoncé un
mépris de la représentation nationale
écouter voilà ce qui arrive quand on
traite par le mépris la représentation
nationale
les alertes ont été nombreuses sur le
risque qu'il ya à s'installer comme si
de rien n'était dans ce qui relève d'un
régime d'exception
l'exécutif a donc fait un pas inversée à
allier du modem en acceptant à
d'écourter la période de transition
cette dernière s'étendra donc du 2 juin
à la fin septembre plutôt que fin
octobre le volet sur le pas de
sanitaires lui n'a pas été retouchée et
le modem qui aurait aussi peut-être
obtenu dans ce bras de fer l'ouverture
des boîtes de nuit pour le 1er juillet
mais ce matin on apprend que c'est pas
sûr du tout encore un oui exactement
magali c'est ce que nos confrères de bfm
tv a rapporté les discothèques pourrait
ouvrir le premier à juillet avec un pass
sanitaire après des impressions à des
élus du modem le parti voyez dans cette
réouverture un signal envoyé pour la
jeunesse mais vous l'avez dit à ce stade
aucune décision n'a encore été prise le
groupe centriste n'aurait donc a pas eu
un gain de cause le ministre délégué aux
pme à lui indiqué que les patrons de
discothèques seraient fixés sur leur
sort le 15 juin est dernier carat selon
le syndicat national des discothèques
sur 1600 établissements 150 aurait déjà
mis la clé sous la porte en cas de
fermeture prolongée c'est un tiers des
établissements qui pourrait
définitivement fermé leurs portes
merci beaucoup extel pour toutes ces
précisions estelle chargeant en direct
de l'assemblée nationale ce matin